كان أفراد الحساء مترددين بشأن ما إذا كان
يجب علينا فتح الحاجز الذي أنشأناه
في الغرفة ،
مرحباً
فتاة واحدة في الغرفة اتصلت بالفعل بـ
9-1-1 تحدث إلى المرسل
وقال المرسل في الواقع إنهم
لم يرسلوا  أي شخص يصل إلى الطابق الثالث
وأنه لا ينبغي لنا فتح الباب
[موسيقى]
يكون حوالي الساعة 8 و 10 آه عندما نتلقى حواء
عندما نتلقى رسائل بريد إلكتروني
وفي رسالة البريد الإلكتروني تقول: اركض واختبئ
وقاتل وهذه الكلمات خلقت مثل
الذعر بين  مثل أي شخص في
غرفة المساعدة طوال الوقت مثلك تعلم أنني كنت
أتناقش معك ، أعرف
ما يجب أن أفعله مثل كيف
يمكنني الهروب ، كما تعلم ، هل
يجب أن أتركك تعرف هل يجب أن أبقى حتى
تعرف هذه الأفكار فقط استمر في
الركض إلى عقلك  كما تعلم أنك
تشعر أنك محاصر